rubba pokecenter graphing amazing thank
you thanks to all the organizers for
putting together such an exciting or
shelfing overall such an exciting
program this semester it's really fun to
learn about all the advances that are
happening so quickly so let me start
with something beautiful already this is
a zone atop and the little movie that
you see is courtesy of no I'm Shawn
wrong friend of mine who is insanely
good with computers unlike myself and so
he put it all together this is a Zanna
top as a matter of fact it's more
symmetric in reality than you see here
here One Direction is artificially
elongated but this is actually as a
little based on the root system of one
of the best-known lis algebra namely a
three and I am afraid I will not go into
that direction
and I'll just hint at various
connections that representation Theory
has with what we call Zahn a total
algebra here I actually will emphasize
connections with lots of other things
that I think will interest you a little
bit more than connections with
representation theory but it's an
amazing subject which emerged on the
border line of algebra comminute Oryx
analysis and I am just happy to tell you
what I know about it I will go fairly
in-depth even though I'll you know
mostly talk about simple examples and
please interrupt me if you feel you need
to understand something better and I'm
also happy to take any questions after
my talk so I wanted to be as accessible
as possible so that ideally someone in
this room who has not seen this before
might be inspired to actually use the
construction set that I will describe
here and maybe get something new out of
them all right so let me start with just
a bit of motivation that I'm very well
familiar with probably not everyone in
this heart
knows what splines are some people
definitely do the here is a here is the
father of splines is a Jean d'Arc who
not surprisingly also had to do a lot
with total positivity with some
combinatorial results with some really
exciting characterizations of measures
you know that reach a real rootedness
and with the la jolla class so
Schoenberg actually knew a lot of stuff
that you know we're discussing as the
classical stuff in our subject among
other things sronger is responsible for
the creation of splines and here is a
spline curve which is just drawn in 2d
its lines are just piecewise polynomial
functions and hundred began developing
this theory if you've not heard of this
you might be interested to know that
splines are actually sort of the
workhorse of numerical computation or
they have been until recently I'm sure
they're still in great use I know Boeing
still uses them on on the everyday basis
and Carl the board who was one of my
sort of informal mentors in Wisconsin
actually was awarded the National Medal
of Science primarily for his work on
splines he has done many other things
but in particular he developed the
theory of so-called B splines and these
are just special bases of univariate
splines but they turn out to be
incredibly useful and they turned out to
be numerically stable so that leads to a
whole host of computational advantages
and numerical methods that were
developed as a result so why am I
telling you this if you're interested in
movies as some of you are or any kind of
computer-aided geometric design morphing
and so forth splines are actually used
there again I cannot speak of exactly
what algorithms were used you might
recognize this this screenshot well this
is the rendered image and then this is
the original acquisition this is what
happened on this set of
as you can guess and you can see zoe
saldana
face actually kind of covered with
points these are not exactly control
points that you see in constructing
spline surfaces but they're very close
to to this control points and they're
being used to actually morph the image
of her face and then add extra texture
and add all this additional enhancements
that you know her image that undergoes
so it's quite surprising that I think
some people might not know how useful
splines are but just in case you wonder
if there is a lot of literature out
there and so if you're curious you can
you can look it up all right so what
does it have to do with Zanna talks and
what does it have to do with Converter
acoustical mechanics partition functions
and all that stuff well here is the
multivariate generalization that the
bore hole a criminai endure Domon
maturely and many other people created
this was about 1980s some of their work
preceded 1980 some of the work was done
past that time and so if you look at the
definition this is one of the several
equivalent definitions of box blinds you
will see that they are based on a matrix
of directions so I will call it capital
X by the way some of this notation is a
little bit unconventional you can read
lots of different papers by now about
what we call them interval algebra and
then if you're more of a combinatory
storm or community of algebra you will
see different variants of notation here
I will just use this capital X and this
will denote a multiset or matrix and for
simplicity we'll just take it to be full
rank I'll speak more about what to do if
it's not full rank so think about just a
bunch of columns
so given this bunch of columns you can
actually associate it to off hand a
distribution which actually is a
function which actually is a complicated
support
piecewise polynomial function given
through its Fourier transform in the
following fashion so you see the
directional vector X that comes so
that's a particular column vectors
vector in your matrix you go over all
possible column vectors in your matrix
you don't have to think of them as
column vectors your choice but let's
stick with that convention and so you
create a exponential with a frequency so
to speak which is determined by your
vector X and then you create a bunch of
the so-called sinc functions these are
actually just this you might have seen
them before these are the so-called sinc
functions you're multiplying all of them
on the Fourier domain okay
so multiplication on the Fourier domain
becomes convolution on the space domain
and that's exactly what you will see so
this is the distributional definition of
your box line it's it's given to you
through its action on test functions and
this is exactly what it does and hence
the name box flight it will take the Box
the unit box which is just the 0 1 to
the power equal to the cardinality of X
meaning the number of its columns ok so
take it we'll take this box and you will
transform your argument which is also a
vector using your matrix slash linear
transformation X and you will subject it
to the test function fee and then you
integrate so this is the distributional
definition of your box spline it is
piecewise polynomial completely
supported and it has certain smoothness
which is dictated by basically how many
times you convolve it's a little more
complicated than that but you can also
determine it smoothness all right so now
what about Donna Tubbs Donna Tubbs
naturally arise here because Donna Tubbs
are actually exactly the supports of box
plots all right so this on the top that
is determined by your matrix ax is
nothing but the image of this unit box
under the linear transformation X and
this is nothing else but the Minkowski
sum of
Eggman's segments being determined by
the columns of your matrix right so this
is exactly what you're going to get if
you look at the support of the
corresponding box one so here's a
picture in 2d this is a particularly
simple Zona top nothing fancy going on
this is not a three-dimensional picture
just shown on the plane it's really
truly a two-dimensional picture and I
took just this three vectors in r2 and I
build the corresponding is on top so
it's a sort of one of the baby baby
examples you can try just to test how
things work okay as I had mentioned
already surprisingly that very modest
object which is nothing but the
Minkowski sum of segments begins to
emerge and begins to connect with many
different fields of mathematics and so
I'll tell you a little bit today and as
I said feel free to ask me more
questions and feel free to you know read
beyond what I will tell you today so it
turns out it is connected with
representation theory this can actually
connect avataric algebra we can do
various things with zonna tops like
they're tilings we can count integer
points and so on tops efficiently and we
can connect all this machinery with
graph theory and various other things a
lot pursue connections with tropical
geometry but they exist as well and
there are connections with various
various models of probability in
statistical mechanics but this I will
speak about a little bit today all right
so to explain how this machinery works
let me just continue with this basic
example I will slightly modify the basic
example to show you that it could be a
multi set so you see a repetition of the
first column vector nothing fancy going
on just this one repeated it's perfectly
allowed because you are allowed to take
multi sets and you can start counting so
in particular you can count the number
of bases in arising out of this
configuration slash matrix X you can
count the number of independent
sets we're counting your you you already
see these are May toradol motions
beginning to emerge and so we can count
the number of independent sets the
notion of basis is the usual notion just
linear algebraic notion of a basis and
here the notion of an independent set
likewise is the usual linear algebraic
notion now here come somewhat
interesting objects is a called internal
basis and for those of us who were here
on Tuesday I believe the notion of non
broken non broken circuits was
introduced I'll come back to the and
I'll show you how this notion is related
to the notion that we heard about on
Tuesday right now let me just give you a
definition of internal basis internal
basis are actually basis with zero
internal activity it's a little
counterintuitive but unfortunately
that's the terminology and I will just
stick with that if you don't like it you
can use a different one different notion
but basically what happens here is that
you take a basis and you test it for the
following property you look at each
column in your basis and you test
whether this column is actually the last
element which is in X take away H where
H is the hyperplane which is spanned by
the by the other vectors in your basis
the other vectors in your basis okay and
if this does not happen to be the case
ever for your basis you declare it an
internal basis so there's a special
basis and offhand it's not clear why
they should be special what role they
are going to play but we will see later
that they actually count something
interesting
all right so here comes a little bit of
analysis or commutative algebra if you
will it's fairly basic but it's very
interesting what you can do so you can
consider the hyperplane arrangements
that are determined by your column
vectors column vectors and your
configuration / matrix and in fact you
can shift so this is the linear form
which is determined by your contact your
ex right and you can shift it by pretty
much anything for an arbitrary constant
which we'll call them 2x there will be
some minor conditions on lambda X you
want to avoid some sort of degeneracy
but other than that you're very free in
this choice so basically if you make a
random choice you will be fine okay and
so you can consider them the
corresponding arrangement of hyperplanes
that will be determined by your vector
of directions ax well the whole
collection of those vectors X and this
lambda sub X's that you've chosen and so
far nothing has happened but then you
can start counting and when you start
counting you will observe some pretty
striking facts so here is three things
you can count you can count vertices of
your hyperplane arrangement you can
count chambers or connected components
of your hyperplane arrangement and you
can count the number of bounded
connected components of your hyperplane
arrangement and so if you were to carry
this whole thing out for the baby
example that we start from you will see
some numbers emerging so in this
particular case you will see numbers 5
10 and 2 and if you go back a little bit
you might observe we didn't do this
exercise but we can start counting basis
independent sets and internal basis and
lo and behold we will see exactly the
same numbers you will see five ten and
two occurring here so just so you if you
want to check here are all the
independent sets and here are all the
basis
and here are all the internal bases I
should note that the notion of an
internal basis is given dependent on the
order namely how you order those columns
in the matrix but as a matter of fact
the number you're gonna get will not
depend on the order so again something
should sound very familiar here so here
I just tried two different orders just
for fun so you'll see different outcomes
of the counting well in terms of the
actual bases internal bases per se but
you will see that the cardinality of the
corresponding collection will not change
so this is not a coincidence and in fact
there were no coincidences here so these
are always true facts here is another
baby example so I apologize that this is
all in 2d it's a little bit harder to
count things you know to show how to
they get counted in 3-d or 4d it's a
little bit harder the number bounded
connected components well you have the
higher plane arrangement your hyper
plane arrangement splits the space in
this particular case the plane into
components great
connected components and some of them
will be unbounded and some of them will
be bounded so if you only count the
number of bounded connected components
this number magically is equal to the
number of internal bases and the total
number of vertices is magically equal to
the number of bases and the total number
of connected components is equal to the
number of independent sets so none of
this is a crazy incidence these are all
facts okay so how does this actually
work and what what's the story here here
is what the Bohr and his co-authors
first proposed so they looked diamond
and Miceli worth also to people who are
responsible for the early development of
this theory so I should know those two
names in fact the spaces are sometimes
called Diamond Miceli spaces you may see
that in the literature
so what happens here you take those
vectors that determine your matrix that
your matrix consists of and then you
look at the corresponding linear
polynomial here you can drop the the
funny lambda sub X you might use that
too it will be sort of the inhomogeneous
version of your construction it does not
matter okay but let's let's drop this
for now and then you can put them
together this will reveal just products
of linear forms so this will be a
homogeneous polynomial determined by a
sub collection from your multi sub /
matrix that you can pick okay so far
nothing nothing fancy is going on you
can also consider it as a differential
operator so this is going to be how much
Amy is differential operator of degree
equal to the number of columns that you
picked and again repetitions are allowed
you can do whatever you want
linear dependences are allowed that's
perfectly okay so if you do all that
then you can decompose the whole boolean
algebra of subsets of X into so-called
long and short subsets so what is long
and what is short you call a subset long
if what happens is it meets every basis
in your collection of aces again you
those of you who work with matrixes you
may recognize this as a familiar notion
from a true theory and what a short
chart is the opposite of long if this
does not happen that means if you avoid
the bases at least one then you will the
corresponding subsets will be called
short so in other words short means that
the complement is what what rank full
rank exactly
so shard means the complement of your
subset is flooring exactly okay here is
just continuing with our baby example
here is the full splitting into long and
short and you can notice that the
collection of long subsets is closed
under taking super sets as it should and
the collection of short subsets is
closed under taking subsets as it
so no surprises here again okay so this
is long and this short and here comes
the early result that was pruned by
dominant Miceli historically the first
result which connected splines with all
this business that I just introduced so
it turns out that if you consider the
set of all polynomials that are
annihilated by this differential
operators remember that came from the
long subsets this is precisely what's
called the local box blind space or the
local the space spanned by pieces of the
box spline so if you look at this this
is the so called space D so people in
approximation Theory slash analysis were
interested in determining the dimension
of this space because it precisely
determines the approximation power of
box blinds and it turns out that the
dimension of that space is exactly equal
to the number of bases in your
configuration X which is quite striking
well I can actually show you more there
is another space namely the one just
given by spanning taking the span of all
short homogeneous polynomials remember
the Q sub y is the polynomial which is
just the product of linear forms coming
from this sub collection Y and so if you
take all the short subsets and then you
take their span which is going to give
you another finite dimensional linear
subspace of space then you will get
another space P and it's dimension is
also equal to the number of bases and
moreover there is a natural duality
between P and D which is playing a role
here these are not I then D is not PE
generally sometimes they can
accidentally be the same but generally
there's a two different spaces but there
is a magic duality between them which
I'm kind of sweeping under the rug here
but we can we can talk about this after
the talk if you want so this second
statement is due to two teams
acqua parents I can and Dean and Ron and
this was done in 1989 and 1990 that
started sort of this called the school
area and it be it it pushed people
towards the understanding which is still
you know developing of how communitary
fits into this and how community of
algebra precisely fits into this so I'm
alone and I have a long paper which is
causing trouble algebra where we
summarized pretty much everything that
was known up until that point and we we
push the those results as far as we
could at the time know we could do more
but at the time it came out in 2011 that
was pretty much what was known at the
time so hyperplanes remember we dealt
with hyperplanes as well we also have
duality going on on the hyperplane
arrangement side namely we have the
primary hyperplane arrangement and the
other hyperplane arrangement we first
called it the duo hyperplane arrangement
but this term was taken for something
else so we actually switch to calling
them the facet hyperplanes so what are
the fasiq hyperplanes if you take
hyperplanes that are just spammed by
some vectors in your configuration X
then you will also get sort of a
hyperplane arrangement so here what you
see is I'm showing sort of double lines
this is the primary picture this is the
original hyperplane arrangement and this
is the dual slash facet picture so you
see another double line emerging here
and again all of this is in 2d this is
very basic alright so there is a non
Annihilator I deal for the second space
P it can be determined by taking your
hyper planes that are coming from your
configuration of facet hyper planes and
taking the vector which is pretty much
uniquely determined well it is unique up
to scaling which is normal to age and
then taking what's called its
multiplicity namely the number of
vectors in
acts outside the hyper plane H and this
will be the ideal that will determine
the space P by the way so you see both
spaces P and D are actually defined or
pretty much defined as kernels of
certain differential operators and you
can check that even if you drop the
condition that you're looking for
polynomials and look among all
distributions then it doesn't matter you
will only get polynomials in the kernel
so this is an interesting fact and you
can just check it directly ok so I
promised you a little bit of analysis
and here is here is something that de
Bourgh and his co-authors did in fact
prior to this to this results they
considered the basic question of
interpolating in RN so we all know
interpolation in 1d the branch did that
and you know their variances of the
limiting case of Lagrange's air meet so
we know how to do that it's an all nice
and beautiful and in the multivariate
case things are far from being nice and
beautiful except here so this is the
most beautiful theory for the
multivariate case and it's in a way
strikingly simple and it's I think
reminiscent of some of the techniques
that you will see in particular in what
we just heard about the other day what
peter brandon and june who were doing
some of these techniques or quite
reminiscent a list to me of what's
happening here
so what happens here you take a bunch of
points so you want to interpolate at
those points in RM these are distinct
points by the way I'm not looking at
coalescence this this is a little more
technical so I'm looking at distinct
points in RM its intercept it's not a
multiset no repetitions and first I can
look at the span of Exponential's with
the exponents given by these points ok
so this is the exponential that you can
construct and then you're looking at the
finite dimensional
our span of this exponential so far so
good
then since we are talking about entire
functions everybody in this span is an
entire function in particular has a form
of power series expansion well you can
look at this far power power series
expansion and single out the first
non-trivial homogeneous chunk okay
so some of them will have no constant
terms fine some of them may have no
linear terms fine so you go and examine
this from this from the beginning and
you come across the first non-trivial
homogeneous piece and you take this and
this is what this list operator will do
it's not quite this multi affine part
operator but it's a little bit in the
same in a similar spirit I think it
works a little bit similarly okay so you
take this and this is gonna be the
result of your operation F down arrow
okay so look at all of them and take the
span this is now a polynomial right this
is a homogeneous polynomial so take the
span of all such polynomials that you
can obtain and you will call this PI
capital PI of Sigma so now lo and behold
it turns out that there is a bijection
between the set of your original points
and this and this span namely by taking
the restriction to the to the original
point Sigma you will create an
well-defined interpolation problem there
has exactly one solution and this is
going to be the solution related to the
problems we've just seen namely if we're
looking for this hyperplane arrangements
and they happen to have the right number
of vertices
I should notice that you know you can
there is a technical condition there
that you should not make your
hyperplanes coalesce for example but you
know more than that the intersection
should always have the right code of
code I mention if you have K hyperplanes
than the co dimension should be k if
this condition is met then the number of
vertices will be equal to the number of
bases and under these conditions the
least polynomial space that you're going
to obtain is going to be exactly the
space D that arises out this out of this
the Bohr Ron and etc constructions so
you can say all of this is old stuff how
is this relevant first of all here is a
little bit of algebra that we can do
these are the mains or algebraic points
you can you can verify that the spaces
are indeed gonna give you full duality
and you can run a bunch of proofs first
of all just related to the dimension of
the spaces and you can check that this
chain of inequalities will hold namely
that the number of bases will not exceed
the dimension of T and the dimension of
D will not exceed the dimension of P and
the dimension of D does not exceed the
dimension of the kernel of the
annihilating ideal I and then finally it
will be again bounded by the number of
bases in X this is a little bit
technical I'm not going to talk about
how you prove this this is a fairly
lengthy business but you can prove all
of these things and this establishes
full reality that all this dimensions
are in fact equal to the number bases in
X
so now we come to counting questions and
you'll see some interesting things going
on
remember our spaces where kernels of
differential operators
so actually trivially they will be
invariant under any kind of
differentiation operators you may want
to use being remember they are kernels
of differential operators so if you want
to differentiate any of them they will
still stay within the kernel and so
right off the bat trivially you'll see
that this is G invariants faces which is
a huge advantage so they are actually
graded that means they're spanned by
homogeneous polynomials and they're D
invariant and you can count dimension by
dimension exactly what you know the
grading is and here is an algorithm how
you can count so there is a so called
valuation function that will do that job
for you
so the valuation function looks at first
of all the answers are the same for P as
for D and the reason is because this
because of the nature of duality there
is a bilinear form that takes arguments
from PMD and this bilinear form respects
homogeneity and because of that all the
homogeneous dimensions of P are in the
same as the homogeneous dimensions of D
which is again an advantage you can
count on that side or you can count on
this side whichever you prefer so
however you prefer to do this there is a
valuation function that will do it for
you so here is how you can use it you
will take and look at all all vectors X
and then you will see whether X is in
the span of the basis vectors from a
given basis B ok that are gonna proceed
X that precede X it could be X itself ok
and if this condition is met then you
count this in so the valuation function
will count all this vectors and the
answer to your question what
the homogeneous dimension in degree J is
going to be given by the value of this
valuation function so however many bases
there are that give you this value J is
gonna be the answer to your homogeneous
dimension question so just to give you
an example again here's what you get
from our baby little matrix there it is
and here is all the homogeneous
dimensions so you will see of course at
the constant level you only have
dimension 1 2 or quit and you will see
you see it here right so this is this is
what corresponds to degree 0 this 2 will
correspond to a degree 1 again no
surprise here you have what's called
full saturation in degree 1 you are both
linear terms and degree 1 and in degree
2 you start losing saturation so you
will see two values equal to 2 it and
therefore the homogeneous dimension in
degree 2 is equal to 2 okay so you'll
see this whole grading going on 0
occurring once 1 occurring twice and 2
occurring two times so your dimensions
are 1 2 2
okay so you have now a homogeneous basis
for P and then at the time we wrote the
paper we didn't have a homogeneous basis
for D but then later Matthias Lenz
produced a how much unions basis for D
so now you can also have a very nice
homogeneous basis for D and you see
those dimensions emerging again as a as
they advertised this numbers 1 to 2 will
emerge okay so it turns out all of this
generalizes actually quite a bit so
first of all you can generalize this to
what's called external Zhanna topple
spaces and you have the collection of
external basis you have the collection
of all the external spaces P and D full
duality the same count the same
valuation function works it's quite
amazing the same annihilating ideals you
have to just be careful with the
definitions and you have to be careful
with the proofs I mean proofs are still
required but you you can do all of that
and surprisingly all of this goes
through so external just means so here
is a construction that gives you
external basis you add any fixed basis
choice at the end of your matrix /
multiset and then you perform a greedy
completion will be greedy completion of
your independent sets to a basis right
so you grab the first column that you
can if you can then you examine the next
one if you can add it you will add this
and this happens until you form a basis
so this greedy completion will give rise
to what's called external basis of your
original configuration and from the
construction directly there in 1:1
correspondence with independent sets and
then you see the whole machinery works
out as as it did before and in
particular you see again the space is P
plus spanned by everything now it's
really truly everything ok and then you
see space Dima D + and so forth and you
will see in this definition as the
kernel that the multiplicities will have
to be bumped up by one
so all of these go through and you have
another interpolation prop problem now
for the vertices corresponding to the
external basis and it gives you this new
space D plus so just to illustrate what
the external basis look like this was
our original configuration and the green
ones were vertices of the original
hyperplane arrangement and now we just
added an extra two lines and we got this
red vertices in addition okay by the way
I went a little bit fast but for someone
who paid attention but I know this is a
little bit harsh made to ask this
question so why am I not taking this guy
I got always read extra vertices so this
new interpolation problem will involve
the green vertices and the red vertices
but for some mysterious reason I'm not
taking this the white one so why not any
guesses
how do i form the new extra basis the
external basis are formed by a greedy
completion of something right so the
white vertex that will occur here here
it is actually does not come from a
greedy completion everything else will
but this verdicts does not correspond to
a greedy completion to a basis so it
will not actually enter this
interpolation problem this is a little
technical so you can do all of this and
all the machinery works out and now
instead of going up so this will enlarge
your sets to all independent sets and so
forth tree instead of going up you can
also go down and then you can do the
interior version of all the
constructions that you would seen before
so internal rather than interior I
should say internal analysis you can
define the corresponding space P minus
and D minus and as you see this will
correspond to this multiplicity is going
down by one in the definition of P as
the is the kernel of differential
operators so you can go up you can go
down all the things will work out by the
way you cannot play this game forever so
you cannot go down beyond this level if
I start subtracting two I will be in
trouble
Federico ardilla and Aleks posnick if
explained why why not these are the
limits of going down you can go up
further but going down it's only
possible to this level at least
uniformly
so as a matter of fact yes so everything
works out so all the numbers agree the
number of internal basis will give you
the dimension of your spaces D - P - and
the corresponding interpolation problem
is again well defined and gives you this
space D - so everything is is working
just as beautifully as before and the
grading is there if the D invariants is
there everything is before okay so you
can as I mentioned already you can
generalize this even beyond the
subtraction of one in the addition of
one in those exponents in fact there is
some work by Amazon and Jiangsu and
myself as well as Matias lengths where
we explore what else you can do you can
do a little bit more well quite a bit
more as a matter of fact and Matias
explained Matias Lentz explained why so
he has this whole notion of an upper set
of a may trade that explains what you
can and cannot do what intrinsic
barriers there are and there are
generalizations by now so to toric
arrangements by Luca Marchese so if
you're interested in Taric algebra you
are welcome to see what he has to say
it's very interesting he has a number of
papers on the subject ok so now back to
sonnet ops
if we are in the unimodular situation
namely if our matrix is Union modular
does everyone know what your new modular
means maybe not what is your new modular
it's a situation where all the
determinants you can form from your
matrix will give you plus or minus 1
exactly this is a union modular
situation and in particular if you look
at the incidence matrix of a craft this
is a prominent instance where you do get
your new modular range and your modular
matrix so in that situation there is
more we can do in particular this on the
top which is again the image of the box
0 1 to the power X under the linear
transformation ax is particularly nice
and the polynomial interpolation problem
that the bore and Ron and others
consider it actually will give you the
space P plus if you base this
interpolation on the points that on all
the integer points in this on top so
this would be including the boundary
okay
and if you only want to work with the
interior integer points of the zone atop
you will get the space P minus and of
course you should expect the space P to
be in between P minus and P Plus as it
should be and in fact you can do that
too
so if you take here's on the top and
shifted just by an infinitesimal amount
so you'll lose some points that were on
the boundary right and you will keep
some points so if you shift that by an
infinitesimal amount then consider the
corresponding interpolation problem then
it will give you the space people so
this interior exterior and
points in in the bulk of the sauna top
they can be all used all the energy
points there can be used to solve and
set well set up and solve very nice
interpolation problems okay so what does
it have to do with graphs we already saw
that graphs gives a give us Union
modular matrices and in fact graphs have
this beautiful encoding probably you're
mostly all familiar with this where you
just have to encode each vertex between
sorry each edge between I and J as the
difference between the unit vector AI
and the unit vector EJ and you will see
the matrix arising out of that which
will have just one little problem namely
it won't be full rank you may just
consider this for a second because of
the definition we made it will be ranked
efficient so to correct this little
deficiency you can delete any one of its
rows and then you will be in the full
rank situation so that's the one little
technical correction you might want to
perform so you can see for example here
this is a triangle with a double edge
encode it in that fashion
so actually there is an extra row that
has been deleted here and that extra row
consisted of what negative one negative
one zero zero so that was the extra row
that was deleted so actually it's a it's
a matrix that comes out of a graph on
three vertices one of the edges is
doubled this one is covered and what you
see here is a full triangle you know
with this extra edge and this is in fact
the baby matrix we already considered so
you'll recognize it it's the same it's
the same guy
so what do you get out of this hold on
toggle stuff if you look at graphs then
you start counting familiar things
independent sets are what or graph
forests these are spanning forest school
and bases are spanning trees and
internal bases are
the unbroken basics executive that's so
you start counting familiar objects
that's exactly right and you see the top
polynomial emerging in the context of
the zone at open spaces well in fact
it's a little bit it's it's the other
way around I should say maybe it's a
little disappointing so you can
transition from the top polynomial to
the Hilbert series of your way of yours
oh no double spaces but not directly
back precisely the following will happen
so here's the definition of the
bivariate a polynomial there is one form
here is an equivalent form and you'll
see this external activity being counted
in the internal activity being counted
in you know one of the definitions this
is often taking as the primary
definition sometimes this is taking as
the primary definition the point is that
there is an intimate connection between
the Hilbert series of the some trouble
spaces I just talked about and the
bivariate at precisely this is the
specialization of the bivariate type
polynomial that will give you the
Hilbert series for the central case okay
and this is the specialization that will
give you the Hilbert series for the plus
case for the external case and this is
the specialization which will give you
the Hilbert series for the internal case
yes the Hilbert series on is the
function generated by the by the
counting of this homogeneous dimensions
if you have if you have a graded
polynomial space then you will go from
degree 0 to your top degree to the
highest degree right and you count each
dimension so this is the slicing that we
were already looking at right so you
count this homogeneous dimension by how
much in is dimension and you record this
in a generating function so this is your
favorite series and it turns out that
the Hilbert series that you will obtain
in all three cases has a lot to do with
the table polynomial
precisely these are the specializations
that you can get so Federer Cordelia and
Alex host Nick I've noticed that and we
also notice that which is quite quite
interesting and just to to mention a few
things that have been just spectacularly
improved Mason's conjecture concerned
the so called independent set polynomial
which was another specialization of the
bivariate Tut here it is okay and the
coefficients of that were conjectured to
be full lock concave and even ultra low
concave and all of this turned out to be
true so Matias lands established lock
and cavity based on the characteristic
colonial results of who and cuts and now
Chris we just learned that this sequence
is also ultra low concave which is very
exciting there are lots of other
connections with a chromatic flow and
other graph polynomials so some of this
is explained in Machias lenses work but
generally and I will finish with that
there is the multivariate a polynomial
of course introduced by Sacco in his
beautiful paper on the multivariate
polynomial so here is the definition he
starts with there are several equivalent
definitions you could use as well and
then you can specialize this further
namely to the bivariate case and you can
also connect this with various models of
statistical mechanics so the way it
stated with this definition this is
actually precisely the partition
function of what's called the q state
Potts model and if q is equal to 2 this
is the so-called easing model by the way
Sokol makes a very funny observation
that these are the names given to models
after the student even though they were
invented by their advisers and he says i
hastened to add the pieces rather an
exception from the rule so so these are
the two models that you will see
and you can connect their
specializations of the multivariate Tut
offered me multivariate taught that will
also give you the chromatic polynomial
and a whole bunch of other polynomials
which are important in statistical
mechanics as well so please read the
paper bicycle it's a beautiful paper
where he explains all this connection
some of them need what's called a
scaling limit procedure to actually get
there but it's very exciting so in this
connection I will pose a couple of
questions but before I do that let me
mention some basic references in this
area so in chronological order of
publication here they are there is a lot
more out there by now these are just
some serve basic works in that area and
as I promised here are some basic
questions so suppose you have a finite
dimensional space of multivariate
polynomials which happens to be the
invariant so it's great it alright
graded by total degree and then you are
composing it's Hilbert series the one
which is described right so you just go
dimension by dimension and measure this
and then put it into a generating
function so the generating function is
unimportant it's the sequence which is
important the question is under which
conditions will you get lock and cavity
or ultra low concavity so maybe it's
very general but it's a very interesting
question in my opinion and another
question you can ask all right
what other partition functions of
statistical mechanics give rise to ultra
or simply law concave sequences so now
it seems like we can connect lots of
things due to the work on no Lorentzian
polynomials to that property and so
maybe a lot of this generating functions
of statistical mechanics are actually
gonna give us ultra-low concave
sequences which would be also very
exciting
so I just want to leave you with three
things that dawn tops are surprisingly
multifaceted pun intended
and all of this might be actually useful
in what you do so do take a look this
down public instructions are not
complicated they are actually nice and
friendly and you can maybe get something
out of them I would love that to happen
and finally there is I'm sure a lot more
out there that can be explored so thank
you very much
[Applause]
in the first case how do you mean the
quadrille of concavity of the uber
series it is an infinite sequence of no
these are all finite because we have all
this spaces that are finite dimensional
so the Hilbert series will always
terminate so nothing here is infinite of
course you can go to larger and larger
dimensions but nothing in what I
mentioned was infinite dimensional
and your question here is it understood
for which being very tough places to
Hilbert Aires is that is another good
question so the question was under which
conditions is the Hilbert serious
railroad I have no idea I've not seen
maybe parent knows something but I have
not seen any attempts to solve this
problem that's another good question
definitely
I should mention one more thing if I may
so you notice that the leading
coefficient of this Hilbert series
coming from the minus space from the
internal space P - D - is exactly the
guy you want to approximate okay so this
is all wishful thinking on my part but
it sounds like if you can get it through
some specialization of a Lorentzian
polynomial right then you can
approximate it efficiently in polynomial
time but I don't want to say anything
that would be wrong
the bivariate odd polynomial is not
homogeneous if it were we would have
been done but it's not homogeneous and
so I don't know of hand how you can
actually carry this out the connection
exists right between the multivariate
and v Ariat but it's a little bit tricky
so I think it needs some work to
actually see maybe it's possible maybe
it's easy to do now that we know that
the multivariate opt is actually
lawrencium so that would be very
interesting
it's not it's not like a whether it's in
4q right it only works but for QE physio
and one problem right but still there is
a connection so maybe you can somehow
explore that I'm not saying the
corresponding polynomial will give you
ultra walk and carry day all the time
this is another good question exactly
so this is all open
[Applause]